ça va ça sent les séances étaient honnis
retomber le ciel terreau allemands
tombés du ciel une fois une fois qu on
se convainc que c'est pas dangereux
s'ils font le bain d'abord nous sommes
chanceux d'être venu mais c'est un peu
nous ait eu
puis mais je suis suisse qui me surprend
c'est l'odeur du foin ici c'est super
bon l'odeur du foin
vous aviez merci d'être une voix me
mettant les deux pieds bien sur terre
vous avez pas dead physique parvient pas
perdu la trace en lui mais ça fait
combien de temps finalement avant de
vous habituer à tout ça et de vous de
vous replacer
ouais c'est un long processus le pire
c'est le sens de l'équilibré
ça commence a pris au moins deux jours à
marchaux des parts de marché la centaine
à mettre quelqu'un passer d'autres
choses plus physiques les plus petits
mousses de stabilisation sans pattes
l'éthique très nitialement il est on un
des espèces et le tonus de musculaire
les gros muscles on veut on peut les
garder c'est à ces deux gars s entrainer
plateforme tous les petits murs de
posture entre chaque vertèbres
déstabilisation tu fais ce qui fait de
nous un peu un chat ça ça et ça prend du
temps revenir puis je dis souvent mais
ma femme fait remarquer mon effort
j'arrête de blanc mais ça sur l'espace
c'était très bien au mois de janvier
mais bon vous êtes médecin vous est-ce
que vous avez étudié les lits vous avez
étudié les corps vous avez travaillé sur
dire 'est-ce que vous est-ce que c'est
comme dans l'ellipse que vous avez vécu
quand on vous dit vous allez sentir ceci
vous n'allez pas sentir cela ouais si
c'est pire il ya un gros spectacle de la
tabilité à l'espace la raison pour
laquelle c'est comme ça parce que on n'a
pas évolué avec l'espace commun nos
environnements de vie alors c'est quand
même extraordinaire qu on soit incapable
de s'y adapter
fait qui est mort était surtout surpris
de voir à quel point c'était possible de
m'adapter cet environnement-là
d'apprendre à voler finalement
d'apprendre à vivre dans culte et la
tête à tête en bois sans que ce soit un
problème
donc c'était fascinant de voir l'accord
s'adapter à cet environnement mais mais
ça doit être construit avez vous été
encore
à votre tour est-ce que vous avez été
malade là bas parce que vive la tête à
l'envers ça prend du temps au système
vestibulaire pour pour s'ajuster
quelques jours en montant puis quelques
jours en descendant
c'est d'ailleurs un problème on se
creuse la tête comment faire pour aider
les astronautes qui vont aller vers mars
oui très variés vers mars il repose
toute une équipe comme on vient de voir
pour les mettre dans une chaise un
brancard puis les aider plus ce n'est
pas la même
ils vont être seule voie qui fabrique la
base oui dans beaucoup de recherches
qu'on fait à bord de la station et osaka
on revient là dessus ça va recommencer
ce qu'on peut aider les astronautes est
tous fonctionnels dans les transitions
et tout est recherché comme le reste de
recherche médicale ça finit pas profité
à la médecine standard parce que des
gens avaient pas en équilibre le plein
et c'est fondamentalement c'est les
mêmes la même biologie sûr c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites là parce
que vous allez on peut on va pouvoir
appliquer sur concrètement quelqu'un qui
est un quinté à blatter dans le moment
où qui a déjà 30 ans père de famille oui
oui c'est peut être à sa note en orbite
c'est un peu comme être alité pendant
des mois et des mois à bien des égards
c'est comme un vie un mélange de
vieillissement accéléré et de deux
problèmes d'une activité physique qu'on
essaie de contrecoeur et que vous êtes
encore plus grands ont ces toiles à la
cathédrale
ce récit donc c'est une grande île des
conneries sur terre on sait aussi vite
que ce sera le bon
ils vont encore disposer ça vous
intéresse encore d'y retourner dans
l'espace
oui j'aimerais ça m'était je lui
retourner en arrière de la file
d'attenté et qu' il ya plusieurs des
niveaux ce sera notre canadien et
monastique il ya johnny qui doit encore
y aller josh et jenny qui ont été
embauchés assez récemment qu'ils
finissent complètent leur formation de
base
donc en ce moment mon focus et les
supporter les missions futurs un
supporter des appellations autant cessé
on est comme un pilote qui travaillent
surtout à l'aéroport est rarement
c'est dans son avis on sait très peu de
choses près bon vous avez tout à leur
dit ce qui était extraordinaire vous
pensiez paul l'odeur du foin
oui à cours de l'été ce que des choses
que je veux dire mon dieu j'avais oublié
que je me sois où ça m'a manqué où j'ai
que vous avez constaté l'ats ouais je
réalise que c'est vraiment le fun la
gravité lorsque je serai maintenant de
café oui je la mets sata wah wah et cela
oui j'ai pas besoin de velcro j'ai pas
besoin
est donné demain j'ai pas besoin d'un
élastique j'ai pas besoin de le mettre
dans ma poche
c'est vraiment le fun l'assemblée
gravité on peut voler mais pour
travailler c'est un perdant oui mais mon
silence poli mal passer quelqu'un comme
ça mais pour cette vérité outils facture
et apprennent à travailler complètement
ouvert au début les astronautes junior
qui arrive on rigole un peu parce qu'il
fonce dans un mur il remplit son le
trahissent de places très doucement ils
perdent tout
alors vous à partir de maintenant et
vous devrez vous avez colligé des
renseignements scientifiques est ce que
des choses sur lesquelles de les
travailler
est-ce qu'on fait des avancées ce qu'on
a découvert de grandes ou de petites
choses là dans votre mission particules
dans le mélange des mots grands groupes
focus sur la santé humaine la médecine
en la médecine en milieu éloigné que ce
soit dans l'espace ou sur terre entre le
même problème avec les mêmes solutions
et c'est toujours été un des freins des
uns des spécialités du canada on se
demande si on pourrait peut-être offrir
sa comm service pour les futures
missions vers la lune ou vers mars
responsable des jurys médical les
internautes avec une application directe
ou à la médecine en régions éloignées
j'étais moi même avant un médecin
rejoignent donc je vois tout de suite
l'applicabilité donc oui on a fait
plusieurs expériences qui ont été faites
à bord des tests énergie sur par exemple
laboratoire portatif ou un vêtement
intelligent qui prend les signes vitaux
sans avoir tous les fils les choses de
cette nature
c'est vrai que dans certaines missions
dans le grand nord canadien ça pour être
fort utile de suivre ou même les
personnes âgées qui est prise à domicile
pour est difficile de se rendre chez son
médecin
oui pour être restée chez elle puisses
te remettre les gens de découverte là
dessus peut avoir des sujets de
reportage merci beaucoup d'être des fois
ça a été très sympathique de pouvoir
ma meilleure des chances pour la
continuation merci beaucoup et bien
aussi au revoir ouais